talk to Chris Morgan a couple weeks ago
and he said pretty much the best part of
writing these scripts each time is
coming up with the Haab speak in the
things were you and to do can talk about
the development of Hobson and creating
this character I gotta tell you he the
character of Hobbs continues continues
to be and we've talked about enrollment
over the years now it continues to be
one of the most fun challenges and
rewarding characters that I've ever
played because we continue to add these
little layers to Hobbs and we've created
a scenario in Fast Five where he comes
in there's an independence that he has
from the core crew on this side of the
law Hobbs speak since things in a
certain way with a certain delivery and
he's talking trash and he says now the
beauty of it is so myself and Chris
Morgan and our nursing partner higher
aggressive you know I mean we times of
worry was been together and create the
most absurd [ __ ] to say but the key is
Hobbs has got to say it in a committed
or found way daddy's got gonna work I
mean that's it just do you tell them
getting excited about cussing it's so
it's really so rewarding I think because
because I'm able to say it in a delivery
that's very needed
there's a little bit of gruff in the
boys but all while the audience knows I
am winking at them constantly I'm having
fun and so hey it's been the best it's
been the best and then to add the layer
of of Hobbes's or girl now in the movie
is a lot of fun and I think where we can
go with that in the future if we do come
back and run again in this thing um we
don't see an enormous amount of hops in
this spill but he was shooting another
movie yes he was he opens the movie in a
very big way and he certainly closes it
in a very big way let's talk a little
bit about the hobby shop right well the
we had to I had other commitments
unfortunately at that time so what we
fit in is what we see in the movie when
it opens the movie it closes the movie
we all agreed you get together with the
studio it's like how do we create a
scenario in the beginning that's
memorable one epic you know it's also
one of the it's also one of the fun
parts about the franchise I think
because of the I think because of the
independence that there is able to come
in we're able to create that scenario if
you have
and many guns the whole thing nothing is
safe and it also set to something I see
I think if we again we come back and
play again or a pass to surprise talking
about working with Jason on that fight
scene because for any character to come
in and actually be a physical threat to
Hobbes is shocking enough it was great
you know we Jason Jason brings a great
level of weight so and Jason is one of
the very few active all of the very few
movie stars who is legit skilled and
fight the chins and and it was a really
great breath fresh air he comes on our
set and we're able to put together this
great fight scene and punctuate it with
a rock bottom
through the glass table because you got
to give the people what they want Lisa
that's what you got it to it I had a
great time fighting with them
and he's great you know it and I give
him a lot of credit
I give James Wong a lot of credit
because it didn't it's a challenging the
franchise is challenging it's like a
crazy family that's challenging and when
you're new and you're coming in but
you're also the responsibility of Jason
had of carrying the movie on his back in
terms of the main bad guy
that's a big deal and you got all these
other heroic figures on this side he's
carrying it on that side give a lot of
credit but he did a great job not fun to
be able to blend your past with your I
loved it I loved it and I was always
fans of always said you should inject
your wrestling moves and I didn't want
to blur the lines but in this case it
was appropriate and so when you're
approaching we are putting this fight
singing together and you want to
punctuate we know there's gonna be a big
explosion and there's a 10-foot spoon
you know you're blowing out the building
the whole thing so you know I go to
Jason and I say hey what have we at the
end we punctuated with this with this
movement with the rock bottom that's
never been seen before in cinema fans
are going to go bananas over this thing
so it's at that moment where jit where
the star is at a crossroad so if their
ego is answering for them then they say
no no you know I don't think we should
it's your big finishing move I don't
want to be part of that or you do what
Jason did which was oh yeah yeah give it
to me put me through the table last
table everything cut us up a little bit
he came with no ego and then when you
come to a fight scene like that the
sequence I got with no ego then you get
magic and that's what we have and then
you get hops saving the day at the end
he is the cavalry that's another thing
too
you bring the Calvary woman I am the
cavalry I love it I love it I love the
lines I love the moment you picking
picking he's dragging a gun that was
attached to a helicopter for a six-night
I've been saying this all day fast aid
I'm calling Santa Claus that's it
there's no other way to go me and Hobbs
and Santa Claus and I'm gonna put Ben on
on Rudolph
you